hi in this video I will talk about gal4
Gaetti system in drosophila in my
earlier videos on gal 4 I talked about
gal for us system so gal for us system
by using gal for us system we can tissue
specifically knock down or over express
our gene of interest so that gives us a
spatial control over gene expression or
gene knockdown so gal for Galaxy system
would actually provide us with the
temporal control on gene expression or
gene knockdown so temporal control is
achieved by another specific
modification in the gal for us system
which is gal 80 so we would go step by
step and look at the mechanism of Cal
for you gal for gal 80 system so first
like the previous gal for us system we
have our driver fly line which is a gal
for line and then in the driver fly line
apart from gal 4 put under our tissue
specific promoter we have gal 80 which
is usually under tubulin promoter on the
other hand side we have responder fly
line say for instance we want to knock
down gene a so we have our gene a RNA I
construct and we would crossed cross
these two lines driver line and
responder line so what would happen and
we would maintain this course across at
25 degree centigrade and then we would
get offspring f1 offspring so in the f1
offspring the f1 offspring have Cal 4
and gal 80 so it would actually produce
gal 4 but gal 4 is actually inhibited by
gal 80 gal 80 is the inhibitor of gal 4
and gal 80 acts as a flap on the gal for
activation domain so you can see in the
gal 4 there is two domains one is orange
and one is pink the orange one is the
DNA binding domain which allows the
transcription factor to the bind to the
DNA to the upstream activator sequence
and the
Bing domain is actually helped to start
transcription so it's the activation
domain and gal 80 is actually inhibiting
that activation domain so this construct
cannot this construct can bind to that
upstream activation sequence but cannot
transcribe the construct because its
activation domain is masked by gal 80
then how gal 80 is giving us a temporal
control so if we see in the next slide
so now we are maintaining the cross at
30 degree centigrade at the higher
temperature so what would happen at
higher temperature both Cal four would
be expressed and gal 80 would be
expressed but gal 80 cannot inhibit Cal
four because at that particular
temperature gal 80 is disorganized and
it is inactive so it cannot mask the
activity of gal four and cannot bind to
the gal 4 activation domain so in
absence of gal 80 gal 4 can easily go
and bind to the upstream activator
sequence region and it can transcribe so
if you liked my video give it a quick
thumbs up and don't forget to subscribe
and also please leave your comments
below thank you